hey trying to silence our senator here
in Massachusetts Elizabeth Warren has
completely backfired on Senate
Republicans the Senate ended up
confirming far-right Alabama Senator
Jeff Sessions for attorney general he
was sworn in earlier today by Donald
Trump late Tuesday night when the Senate
was debating the nomination Elizabeth
Warren read a 30 year old letter by
Coretta Scott King the widow of Martin
Luther King jr. and that letter
criticized jeff Sessions on his civil
rights record the letter was actually
written during sessions has failed 1986
confirmation for a federal judgeship he
didn't get it because of a number of
these racially charged remarks that he
made and in response the Republican
majority senate voted to rebuke
Elizabeth Warren and cut her off while
she was speaking they used a very
obscure Senate rule that's basically
never used which prohibits the impugning
of other Congress members and it
completely backfired check out how it
happened on Tuesday night choosing
instead to chill the exercise of the
franchise by black by his misguided
investigation in fact mr. sessions
sought to punish older black civil
rights activists advisers and colleagues
of my husband who had been key figures
in the civil rights movement in the
1960s uh-huh espresso are Oh mr.
president I'm Julie leader senator is
impairing the motives and conduct of our
colleague from Alabama as worn by the
chair and then he went on to I actually
shut the entire thing down this also
prevented her from speaking about jeff
Sessions on Wednesday yesterday this was
a totally boneheaded move by the
Republicans this was very late i think
the middle of the night almost no one
would have heard about this speech which
by the way is publicly available anyway
if mitch mcconnell had had done this and
by silencing elizabeth warren they
turned it into a national story that
every media outlet is talking about it
might end up being used as footage for a
future campaign ad with video of warren
reading the speech the video is all over
corporate media
this has rallied the Democratic base
after being kicked out of the Senate
floor Elizabeth Warren gave her speech
on Facebook live and millions of people
tuned in I mean this rule is known as
rule 13 rule 19 and 19 yeah which comes
from a fistfight in 1902 that I think is
the Senators were very upset about Ted
Cruz was able to call someone a liar on
the Senate floor they didn't invoke rule
19 oh no this was just too far
apparently move on raised two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for Elizabeth
Warren 2018 Senate reelection campaign
around this within 12 hours of the
incident how did McConnell in the Senate
Republicans not realize that this would
put her on a pedestal and ultimately
make her look better everybody coming to
her defense this is an example of what's
called the Streisand effect and this for
people who haven't heard about it is
named after a Barbra Streisand we're
back in two thousand three she tried to
suppress pictures of her huge house in
Malibu California and by trying to
suppress the publication of those sort
of paparazzi tabloid type pictures she
drew way more attention to the fact that
the pictures exist than ever would have
happened had she just not done anything
let one of these magazines I don't even
remember what magazine it was our
website published the pictures this is
exactly the same thing this is the
Streisand effect it's like when Donald
Trump just can't let something go and
he'll prop up the news story and get
going for an extra couple weeks I
thought the Republican Party was the
party of free speech oh right only when
it's convenient the same way that this
is a party of the free market only when
that's convenient and the party of
freedom of expression of religion only
when it's the right religion send me
your thoughts i'm on twitter at d pakman
today's program is made possible in part
by blue apron i do a lot of cooking at
home but when i'm left to my own devices
in terms of selecting recipes i
basically repeat as vegan producer pat
also says he does roughly the same 10 to
12 recipes and i don't speak for pat but
for me that can get a little bit boring
so one of the great things about blue
apron is not only do you get all
ingredients pre-portioned you don't end
up with extra ingredients that could end
up in the trash because you don't know
how to use them
but you also get new recipes every
single month and this month some of the
recipes in blue aprons deliveries
include crispy barramundi with quinoa
and roasted carrot salad cashew chicken
stir-fry with tango mandarins and
jasmine rice and udon noodle soup with
miso and soft boiled eggs cooked with me
so quite a bit actually that's something
I have done it sums up down on me so pat
pat is thumbs up on me so I'm hugely
thumbs up on me so and i look forward to
actually trying that recipe i think i've
got that one coming next week you can
try out blue apron get your first 3
meals for free with of course free
shipping by going to blue apron calm /
pakman that's blue apron calm / PA ke ma
n